yeah [ __ ] that my hair is yeah hey here
we are my hair is all messed up and try
and fix it I don't think there's anybody
there yet I did announce it like on
Instagram and Facebook and stuff like
that but what do we what do we want to
talk about well what's the show by
didn't you have some mom I did have a
couple yet but um yeah so I had one case
that I wanted to talk about just because
I was just listening to criminally
listed the YouTube channel mmm and he
was talking about some cases that like
really old cold cases that have been
solved in 2020 that were just recently
solved then it was like a really
interesting case well the weird thing
about it is that the reason why this one
stood out was because I couldn't [ __ ]
sworn that I wrote about this girl in my
faceless villain - it would have been in
volume 2 because it happened in 1963 and
you know they just solved it this year
and then I was like god it's like the
details of the case sounded so familiar
but then when I went back and looked at
my book it wasn't in there so I'm like
what the hell was I thinking then maybe
it was something else it was really
similar okay so today we got an old-time
cold case two guys solved it just great
what else we got talking about um I had
a couple of shout outs like new patrons
new everything like alright everybody's
showing up everybody everybody Shawn
I've got bees nest got Melissa always
got Sandra and that's Melanie there yeah
yeah and then Neely yeah yeah everybody
from last night they're slowly showing
up never got 12 people on yeah hopefully
you guys enjoyed that show last night I
had a good time doing I had a good time
doing that show like it ended up being
like we're in 3 and 3/4 hours long yeah
I got pretty hammered you were keeping
it together though you were like yes
you're on hold together you're still
pretty coherent I think well you drank
considerably more than I did because I
was like busy going through the cake
it's like I ended up having one whole
drink on the show and then I did like
half of it before we and then I drank
the rest of it when we went back into
the room but no we started watching
cinemassacre about their VHS box art
yeah which I thought was very
interesting yeah but yeah I didn't even
this [ __ ] happen again so n is the only
time that I was just kind of like I'm
gonna sleep in today because I didn't
get to sleep in yesterday morning
because Pookie woke us up at like 6:00
in the [ __ ] morning so I said goddamn
it I'm gonna sleep in on Sunday until 8
o'clock man cuz that's like really late
for me so of course what happens Pookie
decided she must have seen something
outside like I'm the porch or something
at like I don't even know what time it
was
6:37 arm she was trying to beat the damn
door down and she was like over there
like smacking the [ __ ] vertical why
is a window right next to me yeah
against the wall she does that when she
wants something
hey wake up yeah dude she knows it's
really loud like right at your head and
also she the your uh you know the
bedside table of all the stuff you have
she'll she'll pop up there you'll see
her little head and then she'll like
take her little arm and pull something
off of it get up get up yeah making all
this noise right by her face she's not
like a cat she's like and then she kept
like jumping up on my chest and like
laying across me like that like yeah
she's funny she wanted out she saw
lizards yeah she's like I need to go it
really is and it's like she's I don't
know I like I said I don't really like
her going outside but I know she she
doesn't go far especially in the
summertime she just mostly just sits on
the porch
alright xanadus showed up Tammy Cheryl
mark Mark's fart from his head fart from
the heart okay better view far from the
head a head for it's just me a burp in
it yeah yeah bees nest there yeah
evening
it's like two o'clock at afternoon here
we're still a little bit I don't know I
don't feel too bad I'm yeah I'm not all
that hungover no I'm good
even though I didn't get much sleep
although we just ate he made biscuits
and gravy
yeah made for boiled eggs yeah brunch
yeah or lunch I guess yeah that was a
man it was so good now it's just like
eating it now I'm like oh yeah much I
mean that's only white pepper gravy yeah
saw it with sausage in it it's a redneck
thing like I said that driver that's why
we all have diabetes in our [ __ ]
cream it's that same stuff you get like
on a southern omelette weird Denny's
yeah you guys Cracker Barrel yeah
Cracker Barrel all the crackers are what
are the [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ]
ban that [ __ ] see the race to cracker
all the crackers off the whole barrel
crabs you know you know now that I think
about it I don't think I've ever been to
a Cracker Barrel it's I bet my damn gift
shop I know well they make like a lot of
their money like yeah you know it's just
people every time I went there but
they're everywhere they are as just old
people well and usually most of them too
are like right by the sides of highway I
would I mean I've never been in that
I've been to like other kind of similar
you know restaurants with like a similar
clients out like Bob Evans and Stephanie
it's still around yeah Bob and Bob Bob
Evans is a [ __ ] big step down from
Cracker Barrel it is yeah
Cracker Barrel actually has fantastic
breakfast the breakfast is really good
I've heard that it's like I can't really
eat the rest of their stuff like
chicken-fried steak it's it's just too
like I said it's it's good but did that
the older I get the more my stomach
rebels it like anything that's like over
certain amount of calories it is just
kind of like I'll eat it but then I'm
just like oh the rest of the day I'm
just like my life starving you I know
put you on calorie restriction well yeah
I honestly I feel better when I'm on
calorie restriction yeah because I just
feel
like I love to eat but if I eat like too
much in one sitting I just feel like
complete crap like the rest of the day
and it's like not worth it anymore
getting old sucks man it really does all
right do you uh you want to start this
case here well yeah oh I want to do a
couple shout outs like I said all right
so we have after we recorded the show
last night we got a new patron named Amy
H so hey there and welcome
she might be in um yeah we'll see I
don't know and also thank you Jason
for your PayPal donation I also got that
like I got that this morning and we are
gonna give you a shirt I swear because
he has sent us like a whole bunch of
like donations and it's like he keeps my
shirt and I'm just like I know I know we
just haven't done
make sure everything's written down and
we got you know yeah like I said it's
like you know I'm trying to keep track
of everybody that's like you know given
us significant donations and stuff like
that also I mentioned this on the show
last night but in case you weren't
around B haven't listened to it yet my
short story collection hopeful monsters
the second edition of it is out the
first edition came out in 2009 but the
new edition has like several extra
stories in it and you know I redesigned
it with a new cover and everything and
the print version and the eBook version
are up on Amazon the audiobook version
will probably be up in a couple of weeks
because I have uploaded it and it's
going on undergoing the ACX quality
control process yeah so unless something
is the matter with the files but
generally there aren't yeah with our new
equipment and our new microphones and
sound booth that we have in there it's
it sounds a lot better than those early
ones that we did well yeah because even
then I mean and this you know the Yeti
is is good for the podcast but it's like
for the books
we have that I have that scarlet solo or
whatever yeah I think it's almost like a
$200 mic it's really yeah it was a
really expensive one and it has like the
pop filter it has like all the stuff and
we just have it like on an arm like
inside the closet and yeah with all the
I put all the sound put all the
soundproofing in there so I just go in
and unfortunately I couldn't hook up any
kind of fan for ventilation so she just
because with the noise yeah I wouldn't
be able to just sits in there and reads
and bakes and that's well I can stand in
there now because like you put you put
in a shelf yeah at like
because I was like I don't really like
to sit down and read because I feel like
all yeah
crunched up so I was like I prefer to
stand up and then I can like move around
and I did it more animated I think all
of your audio books have been updated
with the new microphone I uh most of
them are maybe some of the I don't know
I don't remember if I did Rochdale and
fire and whispers okay those are shorter
I could probably do what about manly you
know I might have done mammoth I'm not
entirely sure I'd have to look back
through my [ __ ] cuz I'm I lose track of
like [ __ ] that I do because I had so
much but [ __ ] a really designed 40,000
project well sometimes I do write it
down but then sometimes it gets written
down like I was a four somewhere and
then the scrap of paper gets lost or
thrown away yeah also we're gonna do
like I said this is just sidetrack show
so we're just gonna talk about whatever
tomorrow we will probably do a live
stream at 2:00 Eastern Time and it'll
probably be a matinee a movie review and
I think we're gonna do a scare package
which is a new horror anthology film and
I actually it's funny because shudder
put it up first they put it up on joe
bob's driving reviews show and i started
watching it on there but i think it was
like a friday night or a Saturday night
and I was like pretty hammered and I
think I fell asleep like partway through
so it's like I don't really remember
anything that happened because I was
like drunken that I fell asleep so I'm
gonna watch it again cuz it's from 2020
so uh we'll probably review that
tomorrow it's a I think it's seven
different stories and I think I can't
remember if this is exactly right but I
think one of the segments was written
and/or directed by one of the guys
behind the new MST you know what I mean
the one that was on Netflix yeah that
didn't get [ __ ] renewed I'm so [ __ ]
it doesn't make sense
maybe they wanted too much money I don't
know it just made me so angry like they
you know they did like the return and
that liked however many episodes that
was it was like 10 or 12 episodes and
then they did the gauntlet and that was
only six episodes and as soon as I saw
that it was only six episodes I was like
uh-oh new snow was up that's not good
cuz that's usually I mean that's what
happened like back in the old days when
they were on Comedy Central and they
gave like their their last season on
comedies
roll it was like a sixth season episode
and they were just kind of like yeah
that means we have to like go someplace
else because we're about to get Kaisha
shutter will pick it up I wish they
would it's like because I really really
got into like the new show you know it's
different than the old one but it's like
I dug it I liked it like I liked all the
comedians on it and [ __ ] it was like
pretty funny and uh you know I liked it
was a different riffing style was a
little faster paced and like a little
less obscure I guess yeah but you know
it depends like sometimes I'm in the
mood for that sometimes I'm in the mood
for the older ones it's just kind of
like sometimes you're in the mood for a
Joel episode sometimes your mood for a
Mike episode sometimes you're in the
mood for a new one you know what I mean
but I'm just like really sad that
they're not bringing it back and I
really kind of hope I mean there's so
many [ __ ] channels and streaming
platforms and stuff like that there has
to be somebody that will pick them up
and especially now that they you know
they they did Kickstarter and they
raised all that money and they built the
sets and everything like that and I
presume they still have all those so
because they've always operated out of
their own the you know their own like
studio or their own warehouse so it's
not like they have these huge overheads
now so I don't imagine it'd be that
difficult to the people that were
working on that though we're [ __ ]
Hollywood based a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
up shits had happened down there in
their economy with the pandemic and well
the old show they were never they never
went out there they always they their
studio was in Minneapolis all right so
maybe cuz I know that there's old
what's-his-name lives in Hollywood so
maybe he just went up to that yeah I
know I'm not sure if they because I'm
not sure if they moved it somewhere will
it work because they did have like kind
of bigger names on it and stuff but I
know like in the in the old times they
just had like a warehouse space that
they rented like in an office park yeah
and then they just built the set in
there it was in Minneapolis because
that's where they were all from there's
a lot of shit's happening with movies
and corporations with advertising I just
saw an article there's a lot of these
big corporations that are afraid to
advertise now because if they say
something for instance like the American
culture is so politically polarized that
they can't say anything they'll either
be seen as not supporting you know I
mean
one side or the other you know I'm
thought about so a lot of these
corporations are advertising anymore and
the same thing with some of these people
that normally made movies they're almost
like afraid to make a movie no matter
what they make it will be attacked by
one side of the other so who knows what
this is gonna do they're just waiting
for all this [ __ ] to blow over
yeah I don't think it will but I don't
know we'll see yeah so mega badger said
he watched the Creepshow series last
week which yes yeah I really liked it
it's like some of them were you know
better than others obviously but I think
most of the episodes were like really
really good I went you know I might go
through and like watch them again
actually I think we only watch them one
time you know what I got loaded up ready
to see let's again Omega man it has to
the Hestia ask yeah at the behest it has
to the head eat on eBay they sell these
little [ __ ] pre-made dolls you know I
mean where you can buy the action figure
needing buy a head and the heads look
like actors yeah and then you can buy
clothes well somebody made oh yeah I've
seen that Neville yeah just out of stock
parts the GaN said could the uniform and
everything well I was checking through
there and they got a [ __ ] um Kurt
Russell head that has long hair in an
eyepatch
nice they put that on there and make a
Snake Plissken oh yeah but you have to
find all the little [ __ ] clothes that
go well yeah you know if you can't find
you had to make it well cuz I guess
you'd have to like skirt like copyright
issues and like you know you can't have
things of like actors like without their
permission when it's recognizably that
is because it's recognizably then though
yeah you just they just kind of spell
things slightly different and they tweak
it just a little bit so you could say
well that's not really Kurt Russell but
it is it's smart crustle yeah and I
think they're just doing it on I think
it's not companies I think it's
individuals make and I'm with 3d
printers yeah yeah I mean they scanners
[ __ ] because all you have to do is like
you know do it like in a 3d program yeah
just printing out what strain it out
yeah
eventually I would like to get a 3d
printer so I can make my own um pieces
like fur my board games and stuff
because as it is now and I'm happy I'm
using the game crafter um I actually
uploaded a [ __ ] ton of new games but I
have to like order them to proof them
out and then I'm gonna put a website up
that how because I have like [ __ ] ten
games done cuz I just can't stop myself
but um you know I like that site it's a
little it's slightly expensive like if
you want like really good parts and
everything so I think eventually I want
to get to a point where I can just make
stuff at home like make my own pieces
like custom and everything like that but
you know we'll get there I mean the the
3d printers are have really come down a
lot in price so I think maybe in a year
or two I should be able to afford one
we'll see how it goes but yeah yeah um a
Mega Man you can only find it on DVD
that's what I have DVD they don't have a
blu-ray they have a mega I couldn't find
it I couldn't find her Christ's sake um
Zak's and I got to get my dad on the
show tell stories my dad's not really
sure what the internet is he's heard
about it yeah how old is your dad is
he's not that old has just kind of he's
in his 70s yeah he knows about the
Internet he just doesn't really
understand is that kind of like
television you know that's some people
just didn't make the transition into the
modern era you talked to my dad like
going into a time machine back to like
84 yeah it's like going back in time
he doesn't under he like a lot of and
I've noticed like a lot of older people
don't um don't get that you can like
have a job and like make money on our
own and like oh that that just blows
their [ __ ] well so that's not real
real job that's not a real job you might
be making a [ __ ] ton more money than
them but it's not a job you could stay
they just have they're just from another
time but you know a lot of shits going
obsolete
you know like universities are going
obsolete they're all they said in the
next five years half of them will be out
of business because they've been running
in the red for so long you go to these
universities and you learn something
that's very out of date and you get a
degree that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
you know some social studies or whatever
most of what what they were teaching was
so [ __ ] out-of-date well when I would
make you Nelly
oh yes 3d prints are fun thank you yes
indeed show me them flash like when
Africa in the army oh yeah I did two
semesters of college and realize yeah it
for accounting and then I realized I
went wait a minute hold on Excel does
this yeah it's like I can just like no
like I'm like there's no future in all
this [ __ ] money on this [ __ ] you know
I was I wasn't really I wasn't in the
Box type of thinker and it it all came
true you know I mean most of what they
educate people for and have been
educating people for has all been
rendered obsolete replaced by some kind
of app or software it's just you're not
talking about you're not talking about a
world that that that that is human
centric it's all gonna be I could be a
theatre programs I mean what I did I
mean I have a degree in graphic design
but I just did two years at a technical
school yeah just to learn all the
programs and honestly I'm glad I went
because I really liked you know all the
classes and I really liked all the
feedback and I learned a lot but
honestly on most of the [ __ ] that I
learned about it I learned on the job
yeah you know what I mean the future the
future of Education is gonna be trade
schools and skills like really if you
want to make money right now you want in
the southern states the United States
you want to be a [ __ ] AC specialist
if you can [ __ ] get somebody's air
conditioner work and you can make honors
a thousand dollars a year yeah there's a
deer in the summer you it's just because
we just we just never have enough air
conditioning and you know it's a [ __ ]
miserable job but they literally make
more than a doctor with less overhead
because every single person that lives
here needs air conditioning and every
summer thousands and thousands of
people's air conditioning breaks because
air conditioning is not really meant to
work in this climate it's it has to work
very very hard I mean we've had a Weaver
they're under a lot of stress we've only
lived in this
house for maybe eight or nine years gone
through two is broken like at least yeah
two or three times
it runs [ __ ] twenty-three air
conditioning at my grandmother's house
where I used to live her air
conditioning broke at least once every
summer and had somebody had to come fix
it because it just it gets into July or
August and the air conditions they just
can't take it anymore it's just too hot
and it has to work too hard like to keep
things cool and yeah if you guys have
ever seen the movie office spaces the
office spaces are office space space
office space just ones that was the kind
of world when I got out of the army that
was the world I dealt with all those
jobs went to India now they're all
[ __ ] gone the working in those dim
and what the idea was they had people
that went to college to get those jobs -
and what the promise of [ __ ]
university was is that it was almost
kind of a religious promise kind of was
doing what the church did would do sell
dispensation if like sell you of ticket
into heaven you could go to a university
when you got out you get an easy job you
didn't have to work outside you can work
in the AC where it's sitting down behind
a desk with all the [ __ ] important
people yeah and then you get in there
and you realize how much of that [ __ ]
sucks and then they outsource you the
[ __ ] India that's an N here so why
did you spend all that money on an
education to get you a [ __ ] desk job
you know you had to [ __ ] leave it
eventually anyway go work as a
dishwasher it just you know a minute the
promise that the universities held that
was false
it's just when I was going through high
school they were telling us that
everyone would have to get a degree in
order to get a job so it's really just a
racket yeah that way for a while but I
think that small part yeah I don't think
that'll be just like that yeah it was
because the bank's had worked out some
[ __ ] with the damn colleges are like
we'll [ __ ] little boys yeah now the
loans and it'll be this and that and it
was just a scam I mean like I said I'm
glad I went but I got a grant and I went
to a technical school so yeah way way
cheaper than a university and they
actually taught you something you could
use and yeah they taught me something
the useful Ryan's like I said I knew a
lot of it anyway but I learned like a
lot of the technical [ __ ] that you know
that I probably that I would have
figured out on my own but it was nice
yeah and you can take you can take a
lazy
and and give him a [ __ ] fancy degree
that doesn't mean he's gonna [ __ ]
survive you know I mean you're either
work or you don't either make money or
you don't I mean honestly I really kind
of like I I really like the way you know
when we were going backwards what were
you saying before about old people and
not like not thinking that working on
the Internet is a real job um which I
have encountered a little bit they don't
really understand like how you can make
money off that I'm like well you know I
I write books and I publish those like
through I have like a publishing company
and I published those it's like you know
I can do almost all my graphic design
work online every now and then I have to
go to a meeting with somebody but not
very often anymore
it's pretty much done all through email
and everything and you know and then we
do the show and that's very much
I remember the environment though that
they're talking about it was very [ __ ]
late 1800s Early 1900s style [ __ ]
labor where you had a whole room full of
people working behind keyboards and [ __ ]
like that and a dude walking around
watching making sure they're all working
filled out forms and [ __ ] you know I
mean it's just it's not the way the
world is anymore
oh yeah not for the average person to be
honest all supervisors I'll work whether
somebody's watching yeah you could have
all those people working at home yeah
and you know I mean you don't need an
office people like you know slack off
and [ __ ] like that but in a replacement
most people wouldn't I mean I think I
think that it's overinflated to think
that they people need people breathing
down their neck like to get into your
[ __ ] all the time
yeah like yeah some people a few people
are unmotivated well those offices
they're wasting money on brick and
mortar they don't have then they're
wasting all that fuel commuting to go to
it and then they're wasting [ __ ] you
know I mean all this money just to have
somebody work at a computer yeah they
gonna do it or hell yeah you don't even
have to buy your company I said now they
have [ __ ] zoom and everything like
that you can even have meetings from
your [ __ ] house like everybody's
doing now during the pandemic it's like
well [ __ ] we should have been doing that
[ __ ] a long time ago the company's worse
I don't need to go to a place come on
copy some companies spent millions of
dollars buying computers and then
upgrading them every three or four years
all that shit's gone yeah everybody has
their own computer at home and if your
[ __ ] isn't up to snuff then you don't
get the
yeah I mean mega badger he says I've
been loving working from home through
all this yeah this honestly this is what
I always wanted to do is like not have
to go because you know I works real jobs
laying in 20 odd years you're putting
miles on your car tearing up your car
driving it to their [ __ ] places and I
hated driving I just hate commuting and
especially like burning up your gasoline
yeah and keep their [ __ ] running right
and like for a long time especially when
we were living over here and I worked
over in [ __ ] Orange Blossom Trail and
that was [ __ ] it took me like an hour
and a half to get there and an hour half
back you know what I mean it's only like
20 miles with the traffic and they don't
pay you for your time during that
commute it was not that I mean they were
not officious it was not efficient I
mean now I can just I you know I get up
at 6:00 I go for my walk I you know I do
my coffee and everything like that I am
in front of my computer working by 7:30
8 o'clock in the morning and then I just
like work all day through like until
like 6:00 or 7:00 at night and I get
like a [ __ ] ton more stuff done and it's
so funny because a lot of these
corporations of all these people that
we're back and all this like and you
know green environment system and higher
efficiency you know you're seeing that
now with the pandemic people working
from home but now they're going oh [ __ ]
that means nobody [ __ ] buys our
gasoline
nobody [ __ ] comes to our places of
business they don't work for us anymore
yeah shot yourself in the [ __ ] foot
yeah yeah I mean I mean a more efficient
system means all those middlemen vanish
which i think is good thing ya don't
need them they're kind of like
parasitical cuz they didn't allow an
individual to make money on their own
yeah like I said it kind of acted as
gatekeepers and like I said it's so cool
that I can write books and publish them
from my house I can make it board games
and card games from my house from your
house I can record from my house it's
like yeah we had to you know pay for the
equipment but it wasn't I mean in the
great scheme of things it's way cheaper
than like going to rent a studio or
going pr sent us to a studio yeah I had
to record a show there you had to record
a song there for a [ __ ] yeah anyway um
so they spent all this money for this
[ __ ] studio we showed up and I looked
and they you they were using the same
soft they had like the same
[ __ ] microphone working hearing the
same [ __ ] kind of sound booth I'm
like this is a waste of time you got one
of these at the house yeah you know they
spent [ __ ] hundreds and hundreds of
dollars on this yeah I can't remember
how much that it was a lot that studio
like it costs a lot to rent it per hour
yeah waste of time to smell like weed
because they were making so many rap
albums and [ __ ] they're there the whole
[ __ ] place is just permeated with
weed it was very weed smell weed
smelling yeah that was like a big I
guess I didn't even know it was there
it's in like an industrial park yeah
it's small but they've done like a lot
of kind of big albums and like a lot of
famous people hung out there most like
you said mostly hip-hop and stuff like
that so yeah it's very it was very weed
- yeah it's like we like to do various
things all right so let me talk about
just this one case and then we can get
off on some other stuff now like I said
I could have sworn that I wrote about
this case in faceless villain - because
it happened in 1963 but when I went back
and looked at my book earlier I didn't
find it in there and I'm just like
that's really weird because like I said
the case sounded really familiar but I
just wanted to get into it because it
actually just got solved not too long
ago this happened in um Colorado so this
was the case of Peggy Beck her name was
actually Margaret Beck but they you know
she was called Peggy she was 16 years
old she was a girl scout and she was
kind of like she was at this Girl Scout
camp like with a whole bunch of other
Girl Scouts she was actually one of the
older ones she was like one of the
chaperones or something like that
and so what ended up happening was she
was sleeping in a tent with you know cuz
if it's one of those big camps where
they had like a whole bunch of those
like big tents and they had like wooden
floors you know I mean and it was two
girls per tent so the girl that she
would have normally been bunking with
was sick and so that girl was when and
she slept in the infirmary so Peggy Beck
was sleeping in the tent by herself now
she didn't come to breakfast like the
following morning and everybody got
really suspicious so they go in the tent
and they find her laying in the bed dead
now the weird thing about this is that
one they didn't tell the other girl
Scout's because they thought the little
kids would get upset so they're just
like it was the last day and
so they were just like Oh everything's
totally fine like all the Girl Scouts
can like pack up and go home like it's
normal and they didn't call the cops for
like eight hours or something like that
which seems very weird because they were
trying to get everyone out of there like
before they alerted anybody and the
strange thing too was that for whatever
reason they were like they thought she
died of natural causes
I mean she's 16 well some people might
have heart D yeah but then when they
when the cops came and when the
forensics and everything like that and
like I said this was 1963 they
discovered that she had been sexually
assaulted and strangled
so murdered yeah nobody saw anything
nobody heard anything well this case
sounds familiar you sure we don't I mean
you get a show on this that's what I
thought I was sad because I'm the
details of this are very now we did do
um there was the Oklahoma Girl Scout
murders which was three little girls and
they were all killed in the tent so it
might have been that we were thinking of
this was like an older girl okay um but
maybe it's just weird because the name
like sounded so familiar and I could
have sworn that I have written about it
and then when I was reading about it and
saw the photo is it the tent and
everything I'm like wow that looks
really familiar but it's like I can't
remember if we did a show about it cuz I
thought I read about in my book but I
guess I didn't so the thing about it is
that so when they um so they didn't have
any suspects and have anything anything
like nobody had a clue no witnesses no
nothing so all they could do in 1963 was
they had some scrapings of like skin
from underneath her fingernails and I
guess after all this time they still had
that evidence like preserved and this
case is now 56 years old so in 2007 they
were able to take these fingernail
scrapings and get like a partial DNA
profile and then they did it again in
2019 and got a much better one and then
they did the thing where they go back
just like they did with a Golden State
killer where you know they they go
through the GED match thing and they go
backward through the forensic genealogy
to see if they could find a match and
they found one it's this guy named James
Raymond Taylor now the thing about it is
that they know it was him
but they don't know where he is he
very well maybe dead because he would be
80 years old now dead so he may be dead
and the last the last time that he was
seen was in 1976 and that was in Las
Vegas he's dead
so he's probably dead but they do know
that that's who did it that's whose DNA
was underneath her fingernails what do
they know about to do the weird thing is
that he didn't know her
and they they're not entirely sure like
how he ended up at this camp or how he
did live in that city like you know near
where she lived he lived in a house yeah
and he was married was married at the
time so you're not talking on a vagrant
he's just like yeah
nope they said the only thing they could
think of was that he was into like ham
radio and they said that he did go to
like the area where the girl's life was
like to test some of his radios and
stuff like that so maybe he just
happened to be like in the area and he
saw but it just it was just a very weird
he he had something for young girls
maybe he saw some Girl Scouts or
something one time he had some kind of
fantasy so I'm giving them Girl Scouts
and then he started to try to find out
where all the Girl Scout camps are and
when they go and he knew that they'd be
there at that certain time he went down
there and got one yeah something like
that and that's some kind of because
it's you talking about it somebody who
kind of like Charles right like Rader or
you know like the original nice starter
what's his name it was a pre-planned
Angela and yeah D'Angelo yeah maybe he
wasn't targeting her specifically but
because she was in there by herself yeah
and she and it was a Girl Scout that's
he was looking for he was a D'Angelo
type guy and it was a pre-planned thing
and he had a he had a normal life yeah
daytime life yeah he had tells me he was
high functioning so it's gonna be
somebody like a BTK or he was at that
same Connolly
yeah fantasy prom they said that he did
have a criminal record he'd been
arrested for I believe it was either
sexual assault or something of that
nature in 1972 and again in 1974 he's a
serial sex offender yes so like I said
he was last seen in Vegas in 1976 but
they don't know what happened to him
after that so he very he's probably
like I said if he was alive he'd be 80
years old yeah most don't make it in
1961 which was two years before the
murder he was living in Edgewater
Colorado which was the same town that
Peggy Beck was from he had a wife and he
had a kid and he worked in a television
repair shop and they do think that he
was still living in that town in 1963 so
it's possible because this was the same
town where Peggy Beck lived that he had
seen her in town and knew that she was a
girl scout and went there specifically
targeting her or it could have just been
that he wanted to kill her Girl Scout
she just happened to be the one I guess
in the tent by herself I think it's just
a generic thing he just was he wanted a
girl scout yeah because of their age
they were young yeah he knew where they
would all be they'd be there in that
camp any probably really wasn't real
choosy about how they looked they
probably all looks good enough for him
so he just grabbed one room so he just
grabbed him like I said he probably just
like you know raped and murdered the one
that was in the tent by herself
yeah he WA maybe he was probably in the
wood line watch that's what I'm saying
he's like that because normally she
would have had her roommate that her
roommate was six that was sick that
night he was larger Marie he was
watching with binoculars and stuff yeah
and then he said that once living by
herself I'm gonna go get that one yeah
he said oh yeah out there for several
hours yeah I guess he just like [ __ ]
walked in the tent and just like raped
and strangled her no one heard a thing
he might have been dressed up made up as
a park ranger or something again
yeah you think that that was something
he could help him talk his way in keep
her calm for a minute yeah it's like hey
we saw a behavior dressed like a cop or
something yeah cuz a lot of them do that
kind of [ __ ] don't they yeah like then
Kristen will walk around without anybody
thinking anything yeah and then you know
the first few minutes of interaction
with the [ __ ] victim they're calm and
then he can [ __ ] trick them into
doing something like putting handcuffs
on like that yeah so yeah this
unfortunately like I said it's solved
they know that he did it but they don't
know where he is or even if he's still
alive you did I imagine he is probably
dead that's very unusual for probably
Daugherty well the fact that nobody
knows where he is after 1976 it leads me
to believe that he was either killed
or missing person or something you know
maybe he was put in prison for something
and maybe changed his name cuz like I
said this is like 70s so it's probably
like much easier to like change your
name change your identity and like it
was wife didn't know what happened to
him her wife gone to I don't know I
guess his wife is gone too so I don't
know I don't know if he just like took
off again I don't even know like what
they said he was last seen in 1976 in
Las Vegas but they didn't say like where
his wife was at that point or his kid he
had a kid too
so I don't know like what happened to
the family weird because you think his
descendants would be around and they I
believe if I'm remembering correctly I
believe that they traced him through
brothers you know what I mean like but
the brothers don't know who he is
I think the brothers are dead two
brothers did too but yeah I can't
remember if that was him or if that was
another case I was just a family died
out maybe it did or you know there's no
[ __ ] telling but uh yeah so Peggy
Beck like I said they they finally
figured out who killed her after 56
years she her parents are you know are
dead obviously but she still has three
sisters that are still alive that had
been following the case so maybe he died
a John Doe yeah it could be
so I'm because this should be death
records of everybody yeah unless you
this happened in a state where it wasn't
computerized and his death is too far
back to recompute ur eyes it so it's
just on paper and it's in some [ __ ]
file somewhere yeah maybe destroyed by a
fire something like that but yeah so
they're asking Jefferson County
Sheriff's Office is asking anybody they
have a tip line 303 271 five six one two
or call metro Denver Crimestoppers for
any information about whatever happened
to that guy if he's dead if he's alive
if he's alive where he's at and all this
other kind of [ __ ] cuz uh they want to
talk to him so you know um uh is there
anything else that you needed to go into
me yeah
no just reading with anodize I'm
surprised you guys aren't terribly
hungover F Street yesterday so we're uh
season two drinkers I was a little bit
hungover this morning but not too bad
like as soon as I got up I checked a
bunch of water
took three aspirin and I was pretty much
fine just a little sleepy cuz I woke up
a little earlier than I would have liked
cuz Pookie was gettin you know in my
grill again I slipped it off yeah yeah
cuz you actually cuz you Pookie woke you
up too but you actually went back to
sleep
like I couldn't cuz it was like yeah
once the Sun comes up I can't really go
back to sleep again it sucks I wish I
could take naps in the middle of the day
but I can't anybody got any questions or
anything about mango badger says I
thought you were gonna say he was
dressed up like a girl what rich tripped
me out if he could pull it off yeah many
many he was very pretty well I saw a
picture of him from back then they did
find a picture of him from back then
from the 60s um I couldn't see as it was
only like his head and shoulders I don't
know I don't know if he could have
pulled off a Girl Scout uniform you know
yeah yeah he must have died kind of just
in a normal way it was something didn't
didn't really attract much attention so
it wasn't remembered yeah years after
his death it wasn't good because I feel
like that kind of crime and the fact
that he had been arrested twice before
for similar things that would lead me to
believe that if he was still alive after
1976 he would have done more of these so
now I'm kind of wondering if they're
gonna find out later on that he is
actually some kind of serial killer you
know I'm saying maybe he did change his
name yeah because like I said that was
easier to do in the 70s yeah you know
they didn't keep track of people they
didn't have like nationwide databases
and all that kind of crap cuz oh he
killed his family i that occurred to me
also that occurred to me also they were
never found
I'm like I said so there might be like a
whole bunch of other unsolved crimes and
now that they have his DNA profile and
they know who that [ __ ] is maybe
they can like plug in some other like
unsolved murders from that area he could
have been his wife and his kids you know
weren't world well-known you know or
they didn't really have any family so
maybe you could disappear your own
family no one and if you change your
name no one would ask any questions true
because they were never reported missing
that was a weird thing about a lot of
these [ __ ] Hama
sighs you've been looking at it you can
kill a person as long and they've never
even known it it's not they're not even
reported missing yeah well they they say
that too don't they they like if there's
no body or nobody reporting missing is
like nobody knows to look for yeah it's
like it didn't even happen which is
horrifying yeah but you know you think
like there's this system in place this
universal system that if a [ __ ] [ __ ]
just drops off the radar that somebody
somewhere it goes in a control room
somewhere goes hey what happened that
person no it's not it's not at all it's
not like a matrix stimulation where
every single person is accounted for
no we've proven over and over again that
you if you're killed and they find your
body but there isn't a bunch of
relatives asking questions constantly
and pestering the police a lot of times
they just kind of well we'll figure out
it we'll figure it out yeah whatever
maybe people will accidentally solve
that well like I said they do have a lot
of like crimes and [ __ ] like that on
their plate and I definitely do think
that if you disappear it really helps
having a family that just like keeps
hammering and yelling where is this
friend like keeps go to the media and
keeps talking about and stuff like that
because if you don't do that then
they're just gonna forget about it and
like new crimes will happen and it'll
just get buried underneath the pile and
everyone's gonna forget about it he may
have disappeared his own family and then
change his name back in the seventies
and then just vanished off into obscure
way I kind of hope he's still alive -
Megan Kennedy and wouldn't the chances
of a man of that generation making it to
80 are pretty slow that's true although
I could I would have met unless you're
very wealthy I would have been a
substantial sum of money that the Golden
State killer was dead and they found his
old ass didn't ya he wasn't 80 though
that's true he was in his 70s till he
was younger um for if you're a man to
live into your 80s in an American man
you better have a lot of money yeah
because you know that and like I said
that generation particularly I didn't
usually live that long no smoking and
drinking the way they did and eating
what they ate I mean believe steaks and
one of the gates for lunch ever you look
at people that are still in control of
the world like [ __ ] child
Island man and all his buddies the [ __ ]
that the amount of money that they spent
to stay operating in their 80s is
[ __ ] yeah this is Orban it [ __ ]
amount of the amount of
[ __ ] medical bills I mean you know
they're flying [ __ ] blood from
[ __ ] teenagers they're flying houses
like on [ __ ] private helicopters and
they're treating them in their [ __ ]
matches giving them [ __ ] blood sure
wouldn't surprise me if they're like
growing their own clones on the [ __ ]
baby they're like taking their organs
yeah no they're getting although you
don't need a whole clone nowadays you
can just yeah they're brothers they're
evidently China selling all those damn
human body parts out of Weger those
leaguers that they have in the
concentration camps and our rich people
here have [ __ ] first-choice on them
didn't like one of them guys one of them
I think one of those Rockefellers he
said what three heart transplants yeah I
think it's one of the Rockefellers that
he's in his 80s he's on his third heart
transplant think of all the people that
could have used that old [ __ ]
um OBS movies wants to know boxers or
briefs I know the answer to that
commando
yeah he likes to feel the breeze yeah
here's some a lot of people don't know
you
Zacks gonna love this infantry troops
are [ __ ] shave their porn stars they
are [ __ ] that they're totally shaved
and then [ __ ] in Iran commando and
the reason why we wore those big old
long shirts is so you could walk around
your fly open because when you're
[ __ ] when you're rockin [ __ ]
carrying 130 pounds on your body you
need a lot of [ __ ] ventilation and if
you have any [ __ ] hair or anything
like that just [ __ ] rubs and [ __ ]
cut sweat and [ __ ] and you're not taking
a shower for [ __ ] a month it's at a
time sometimes so you can't have anybody
here yeah you know you're gay they'd
smell you coming yeah you're basically
taking a shower with [ __ ] handy wipes
yeah carry we carried around big old
thing of handy wipes didn't and just did
it like that and which is why I just I
don't know man there are some females in
the infantry I don't know how
I don't know it wouldn't have worked out
and in my time the way the infantry is
most of the unit's now are the they're
kind of like trained like world
policemen or at least they used to be
which is a [ __ ] bad idea that's not
warfare that's how you lose a war to
train that way and they they weren't
doing much field time and they weren't
carrying much weight they they just it
was more of a semi mechanized [ __ ]
warfare that looked a lot like law
enforcement females really couldn't have
made it in the infantry [ __ ] in my
day not only of Sanitation just how hard
they were running you know privacy
I don't think a woman would have been
too [ __ ] comfortable she was if she
was a lesbian maybe because there's no
privacy well you know and yet privacy
would mean lack of security what you're
gonna go walk off and take a dump
yeah you know an enemy territory you
gotta have something of garden you yeah
you know so it's just not and my day
women didn't want to do that they say we
say they'd want to do that but then when
they saw the amount of work and the
[ __ ] the suffering and [ __ ] it's
one long [ __ ] tough man competition
it's a war between tough guys if you're
tough then you're too [ __ ] weak you
got me tougher the tough it was [ __ ]
hyper masculine hyper macho you did
things the hard way to prove how hard
you were in other words they're the kind
of [ __ ] ever put a rock in your
shoe because your shoes were too
comfortable that was the [ __ ]
mentality yeah oh you know what this
this feel problems too easy let's not
sleep today it's not sleep for two days
yeah this will kind of up the the
difficulty level so this whole minute
this whole thing I'm making things
easier this didn't exist in my time it
was a brutal kind of like the Navy of
the 1700s it was brutal yeah you know if
it wasn't brutal than it was fake no as
[ __ ] [ __ ] there yeah somebody asked if
we were gonna do a show about Michael
Aquino and the temple upset that is
actually on my list yeah for the next
couple months it'll be up in the next
couple months I'm not sure how
interesting that would be yeah maybe
keynote kind of everything
come at it from memory from nowadays
that she would probably be up there with
LARPing live action we can talk about I
actually if you want to do that we can
talk about that and we can talk about
like the Church of Satan and like how
they've been trolling people like yeah
and it's a life away because that kind
of [ __ ] cracks me up yeah what I think
the best thing about the Satanists is uh
I think is that they've convinced people
to take them seriously
the [ __ ] Satanists the whole thing is
to just a [ __ ] troll yeah I mean I do
believe what they're saying but they
also troll the [ __ ] out of you yeah yeah
which okay looks like I said it's you
know it's go you put that okay gonna put
Jesus said we're gonna [ __ ] make it
put it at you know the old Baphomet yes
cuz we get to do that too which I just
think is hilarious that is hilarious
well it's the best way to do that
because it's like pointing out Hood
Parker hypocrisy um
stop propaganda says did they make you
do the [ __ ] with only one sheet of
toilet paper I've been told that and it
may be a lie
we're not no basic training and stuff
and any in your units you know you can
use all toilet paper you want but when
you're in the field especially if you've
been out there for a couple days eating
MREs I mean you make it you trying to
make me say some graphic [ __ ] stop you
the turd that mris me is almost kind of
like Gracie Plato you don't need very
much toilet paper especially if you
don't have any hair crack crack hair
because you shaved the MRE MREs come
with toilet paper it's enough and then
you can use the [ __ ] handy white you
just carry like I said those big ol
things too [ __ ] handy wipes just kind
of sanitized yourself see that's kind of
that's that's thinking ahead that they
put the toilet paper in with the MRE
sure that goes in this end and then
here's that for when it comes out the
other end yeah and it's it's all
self-contained you have enough now you
know you can get along without it to you
know [ __ ] if you know how to use sand
and dirt the right way you have water
supplies you know that you catch a cold
car
people think people think that living in
the wild is difficult it's not you adapt
to it very quickly and then it's also
not very dirty you can stay very clean
and in that environment if you know how
to Indians did it yeah I mean you don't
really as long as you have water access
to water well yeah staying it you can
stay clean yeah yeah and your hygiene is
actually good you know you can you can
clean your teeth a bunch of different
ways to clean your teeth there's money
you can jump in the water every day and
take a bath clean your hair yeah you
know lot of stuff you can do like I said
as long as there's water yeah um miles
say fast please tell us about all the
different projects you both are
currently working on youtube vids books
games puzzles and artworks etc yeah
Jenny it is so yeah what as far as
YouTube videos we kind of just wing it
these ones like especially the side
tracks and the matinees and stuff like
that we just kind of do those like
either on the day or the day before like
I don't plan for those the regular
YouTube videos we I usually have them
planned out like a month in advance like
I'll write down like them what we're
doing like every week that month you
know at the beginning of the month I
figure it out and I do that sometimes
with the movie retrospectives to not
always because sometimes I like move
them around like if somebody sends us a
DVD or something like it like a short
movie I was wanting to do like comes up
on shutter or something and I'll switch
something around as far as that as far
as books go I'm working on faceless
villain for which will be I'm not sure
whatever I probably call it faceless
villain millennium or something like
that cuz it's gonna be unsolved murders
from 2000 to 2019 so I'm hoping that
done by the end of the year but we'll
see because you know I've got a bunch of
other things we're doing the cookbook
obviously again I want to get that done
by Christmas because we've got like all
the recipes like what we want in there
and we just kind of have to sit down and
write engineer and like because we have
them all like we have them all all the
ones we want to do we have them kind of
separated into categories and then I
just have to figure out like how I want
to best like put the [ __ ] together and
like I said I have a whole bunch
board games and card games that I've
been working on I just uploaded a bunch
of them to the game crafter and I'm
gonna slowly start ordering proof copies
of them like you know because they're
kind of expensive so I just try to get
them like one at a time before they can
go on sale and the one I'm working on
right now is actually it's kind of based
on I'm not sure what I'm gonna call it
yet but it's like a really big board
game that's kind of based on Halloween
like trick-or-treating candy type of
stuff it's gonna be a thing with like
little characters and they're going to
be getting ready for Halloween they're
going to go buy candy they're gonna go
buy little costumes that they're gonna
like you're gonna put the costume like
on them and then there's gonna be like a
demon that's gonna come after them like
and they have to change costumes and all
this kind of stuff so I'm working on
that one I haven't decided what I'm
gonna call it yet but that that'll
probably be the next one that's done but
like I said I have one that's like
absinthe based it's called the green
hour that has like all absinthe bars I
have an Edgar Allan Poe trivia one I
have one based on you know Mary Shelley
Percy Shelley Lord Byron haunted summer
type of thing I have it's called Villa
da da T I have one to call it that and
it's just a whole bunch of other ones
too
so uh that I'm hoping to have all that
up soon as well I also want to do a
board game based on the cabinet of dr.
Caligari like I want to do like a German
expressionist
yeah kind of love it because that's just
one that I want to do I haven't figured
out all the rules yet but yeah I'm
working on Halloween themed going
Halloween candy they're asking about the
Florida the pandemic in Florida okay the
pandemic in Florida I mostly just kept
my oh wait let me see them flash ball we
live in Seminole County yeah it's a
pretty big County next to Orange County
right next to Orange County so I mostly
just watched the results for our county
because if you look at the damn Corona
map the danger that this virus presents
really is a location specific okay well
I mean obviously it's gonna spread
faster in places with higher population
relation density and also subway systems
and [ __ ] like that so when you look at
when you look at Seminole County we're
where we are there were only like six
that's it to this day because I just
checked it a couple days ago there's
only like 600 confirmed cases in
Seminole yeah in Seminole County I mean
you know isn't a huge County but it's
it's very um it's not rural but it's
like suburban so it's kind of like
spread out it's not like a huge
population out of those 600 cases only
14 people died and they were all old
people so it's not a factor here for
people of our age but like I said cities
are dealing do you know Orlando Tampa
they've had like a huge spike because a
lot of [ __ ] reopened in people well
they're on public transportation some of
them there there's a bunch of different
factors as demonstrations going on
people really don't give a [ __ ] about it
they're they're getting it they're
spreading it there have been confirmed
cases and there have been deaths but
most people catch it in their
asymptomatic so and they don't even like
I got sick I even really good I didn't
go to the hospital didn't even report it
for all I know that was Kovac was around
that time yeah it was it was earlier
than its earlier than everything like
not locked down but yeah I could have
but here's the deal when I was sick
during that time in Tijuana um kind of a
salons dad who was in his seventies died
the reason the cause of death was an
anomalous flu yeah so it might have been
that yeah and that's what that's what
the Mexican doctor said and this is
before Kovac supposedly had gotten here
but the outbreak was happening in China
so me and comm believe that kovat was
here and in Mexico weeks before they
locked down well yeah probably one it
was already there's no way that cuz
there were Chinese here I mean there's
no way and if you didn't really know you
know what I mean it because it seemed
like it took a while like for you know
panic about it to kind of set in and you
know they didn't lock down it's like all
it takes is one person like over on a
plane like you know a tourist or
something like that and you spread it to
like everybody especially you don't know
you have it
so it's like it wouldn't surprise me if
they found out that it was here like
before everyone was kind of completed
there's a lot of panic mongering and
politics is behind it in the upcoming
election has a lot to do with it as soon
as that started seeing that certain
behaviors were going down party lines I
realized I knew what I was looking at
Democrats are wearing masks and
Republicans weren't Democrats want to
lock things down so as soon as I started
seeing us a split in the in the in the
thinking the ideology behind it I knew
that there's gonna be a bunch of fakery
one way or the other just look at the
[ __ ] amount of people that actually
catch it and recover the recovery is
very high you look at who dies and you
break down the ages of who dies old
people die there has been a couple of
young people nationwide but a couple
young people die of any [ __ ] type of
damn flu every year there was a little
kid that died [ __ ] guy that I worked
with [ __ ] years back his friends
little kids died from a cut on his ankle
cuz it got mud in it cuz he was digging
outside just some kind of weird [ __ ]
parasite guy him and killed the little
kid you remember that what was that show
that we always used to watch that was on
like that the Discovery Health or
whatever it was like monsters inside me
was yes called that's a [ __ ]
horrifying show you killed my [ __ ] you
never even owe me you could just be out
like [ __ ] digging in your yard you
know like just taking a walk or
something like that you get bit by some
mosquito or you like trip on something
and get some weird bacteria like a
general egg and you're the kid kid cut
his ankle on a root while he was digging
out in the backyard and eating the hole
was only eight inches deep just had his
feet in the hall yeah and it something
got into that cut and it killed him then
you fought for his life for weeks in the
hospital so no little kids catch it and
survive young people catch it and
survive it's it's mostly something that
kills old people that has that that have
a whole bunch of other problems like my
dad would be a good candidate to die
from this all the heart bypasses and
yeah and I'm being selfish my dad my dad
chronologically is in his 70s but
because of his diabetes you look at him
he looks like a man in his late 80s you
know he's very warm down a lot of his
teeth are missing
falling out from [ __ ]
he's got very bad blood flow in his legs
upright cut his legs off eventually it's
very common with yeah it's just it's
just luckily I didn't get that [ __ ] I
don't bleep like getting it checked
because I dodged that bullet well I
would have I would have showed symptoms
already I don't know I think it's
something you have to keep mama I'm like
because you never know when it's gonna
like [ __ ] well if it starts kicking
in this late then it I don't have enough
time left in my life for to really do a
lot of damage to me he's been he's been
fighting it since his 30s yeah that's
true okay so that's a whole lifetime
where the fight against that [ __ ] so
it's just isn't it it's not good to
catch the [ __ ] if you're old and you're
[ __ ] have a bunch of well the thing
about it those are cooling abilities
you're overweight you got a [ __ ] but
you're bad health you're older you you
you could you could kill you now some
people are saying there's like some
people think there's a racial a kind of
a racial element to it because it seems
like black people have a higher
mortality rate but one of the
explanations I heard is because it also
tends towards comorbidities like a lot
of them are also overweight and a lot of
them also have diabetes and [ __ ] like
that
and it's just kind of skew and the
skewing the statistics slightly and it's
not really race that's doing it it's
other yeah it's other fact it's other
factors it's diet and the diet with
diabetes and overweight yeah or they
might live in community in the areas or
higher yeah and it starts cue and start
skewing the statistics but manages I
don't think it's a huge threat I think
without it just so I could just open
everything up and allow that [ __ ]
nature to take its course get to call me
back run and let the people who are
gonna die let him die and it'll go back
to normal a lot faster if you [ __ ]
stretch this [ __ ] out too long people
will die for a bunch of other reasons
like economy start collapsing and
starvation and civil war and because
these this dam brewing civil war has a
lot to do with the lockdowns
they're ones feeding off the other the
frustration so I think you can the only
way to get outside without getting
arrested in these areas is to go protest
you go to a church in that area they'll
[ __ ] arrest you but if you can go out
and protest though it doesn't make any
sense it's politics its politic somebody
asked if are we just a youtube show show
now are we still concentrating on the
podcast I do actually put up audio
versions of most of the shows I've been
slacking on doing audio versions of the
matinees just because I've had some
technical issues but generally the movie
retrospectives the witching hour and the
regular episodes I almost always put the
audio version up as well and it should
be going to iTunes if it's not I don't
know what the problem is but I'd have to
go check I guess if it's not gonna abide
yeah we started off kind of asset
podcast but we just evolved into a
youtube show yeah and especially now
that we started like you know live
streaming we have like the video
component now which actually made things
a lot easy you actually you might want
to drop podcast from the name but we do
put a podcast up yes that I have no we
have no interaction with podcast people
they don't contact us they don't seem to
pay us well not that I know of that's
like you know it seems like most of the
interaction is yeah YouTube yeah or
people that watch the show on YouTube I
have like gotten messages from a couple
that you know that listen to podcast
things usually I'm not contacted by
though so um well we've gone on for an
hour already
yeah you ready to wrap yeah like I said
we'll probably be on tomorrow probably
around the same time 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Time and we're gonna be reviewing a new
horror movie called scare package which
is a horror anthology that's on shudder
so we're probably gonna watch that
tonight and review it tomorrow afternoon
so I guess that'll do it for Sunday have
a good rest Eeyore weekend and we'll
talk to you guys again tomorrow